I can imagine that seeing someone smile could be,...
...is probably a really pretty thing to see.
When I could see, I loved, I loved having eye contact with people.
And I loved it when people smiled you could see the smile in their face...
...and the smile in their eyes.
Oh my god, it just vibrated!
Oh, that's really cool!
It's vibrating!
When I first got it, I just thought it's gonna be a bit of fun.
But actually it's like, it's really special.
It's something that people just take for granted,...
...knowing that they're being smiled at.
But when you don't know that, you're kind of missing that interaction.
So, when you know, through this, that you're being smiled at,...
...it kind of makes you feel that, "Oh that's nice, someone's smiling at me."